so now let's talk about some days with
stars casting news rumor has it married
pros pita and Max will have married
partners as well I like this our source
says Nick and Vanessa Lachey are in so I
guess Nick must have had a change of
heart
yep we remember Nick roll the tape I've
said this as many times as I can
remember and the answer will never
change I will never do Dancing with the
Stars you already want it so the only
thing I could do is match him and the
chances of that happening are not good
Never Say Never
Nick dancing is in his DNA brother drew
won the season two mirror balls her own
show and Nick and Vanessa were in the
ballroom cheering drew on when he
returns for the 2012 all-star season now
the married couple of six years will be
back in the ballroom this time to
compete and a source tells us quote the
show isn't holding back this year they
really want this to be a big season and
one of the ways they'll do this is with
many rivalries you're ridiculous we
already told you about the face-off
between twin contestants WWE star Nikki
Bella and property brother drew Scott
and now Nick and Vanessa at a married
couple rivalry and we're hearing they
may be paired with newlywed pros max and
PITA
he does rehearsals have already started
and if she is paired with Nick we bet
they will bond over babies Nick's third
child Phoenix is just 11 days older than
Peter sunshine now of course ABC is not
commenting on casting yet but they will
announce the full list on September 6